[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER PAGE: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to our session.
It's the first
time I've done one
of these in a movie theater.
And the seats look
very comfortable.
So try not to fall asleep.
But if you do, there
is a full recline mode
apparently on one of
the buttons there.
So I see a couple have already
taken advantage of this.
OK.
So we're going to be talking
about building a Global Data
Presence with Bigtable--
that's a title.
And my name is Carter Page.
I'm the engineering lead for
Cloud Bigtable at Google.
And today joining us is going
to be Subhasree Mandal, who
is a principal engineer
in the networking group,
and Doug Mcerlean, who was
an early architect of Cloud
Bigtable.
And he will be our
DJ during the demos.
So we're talking about
moving communication--
moving data around the world.
And moving data quickly--
low-latency access to data
has always been an
important and valuable thing
to leaders in business and
governments, et cetera.
You go back to 490 BC, you
have Pheidippides running
the distance of a marathon to
Athens and in his last dying
breath, announces victory
over the Persians.
You fast forward just
another 2,000 years.
And you have victory over
Napoleon at Waterloo.
And the Rothschild
family at this time
had a famous communication
network throughout Europe.
Their families spread around
the continent and in England.
And using horses
and people and maybe
carrier pigeons at
this point in time,
they transmitted information
of the defeat of Napoleon
a full 48 hours before the
prime minister's own messengers
got word to them, allowing them
to make a run on British bonds
and increase their already
massive fortune in a very
famous case of
information arbitrage.
Just 200 years
later and now you're
able to transmit entire copies
of the Library of Congress
around the world
in just minutes.
And it's a truly amazing
accomplishment for mankind
if you think about it.
Even just 20 years ago,
if you wanted to do this,
you'd be better served
by throwing digital tapes
in the back of a FedEx truck.
So now you can move this
data around really quickly.
But the hard part is actually
keeping actual data corpuses
in sync on opposite
sides of the planet.
And that's a little
bit what we're
going to talk about today.
So we put out a blog
post this morning.
We announced that
we actually went GA
with the global replication
for Cloud Bigtable.
And what this will
allow you to do--
and we'll go into
more detail in a bit--
is it will allow
you to replicate
your data between any four
regions around the world.
So you can have them
two zones in one region,
two zones in another region.
Or you could have one zone
in each of four regions.
So this gives you data look--
actually let me go back
to this for a second.
So in addition to the
immediate access--
so one of the things
I want to point out
is this basically gives you
low latency access for each
of the different data points.
So this means a smoother
experience for your customers.
Imagine you have your
customers in one country or one
continent.
And maybe you have call centers
on the other side of the world.
If they both have low-latency
access to the same data,
it's going to be a
better experience.
It's going to be less
lag time when people
are calling on the phone.
There's a bunch of
other applications
we'll get into, as well.
Another value here
is unified analysis.
Imagine you're collecting data
from a bunch of different sites
or users around the world.
If you don't replicate
into a single place,
then you have to run ETL jobs
as something to pull it in.
This just gets your
data within minutes--
usually within seconds, in
fact-- to a single place.
And you can run your analytics
workloads in that location.
Pick one of your zones to do
for that type of workload.
And the last thing you can
do is you basically get
an out-of-the-box disaster
recovery solution.
So you spin up
another zone that just
sits there to be ready in
case you have a problem.
And we can either
automatically failover
or you can failover
manually yourself.
And then you get
data localization.
You specify exactly where
you want the data to live.
And this is obviously important
for finance and other sorts
of industries that have strict
jurisdictional restrictions
in terms of where the data sits.
So today I'm going to talk about
what Cloud Bigtable is and get
into the details--
the global replication
and how you can use it.
Then Subhasree is going
to come up and talk
about our global cloud network--
the fiber that spans the globe.
You probably heard about this
a little bit in our keynotes.
She's also going to get
into the software that
helps to make it work.
And then Doug is going to
give us a demonstration
just to show how easy it is to
actually set up a global data
presence on the stage.
So and just so
we're not cheating
by using like a
small amount of data,
we're going to start
with 10 terabytes--
12-- sorry, 12 terabytes.
And it's not instantaneous.
It does take some
minutes to start copying.
So we're going to start with
Doug and get that copy set up.
And then we'll come back to
it later in the presentation.
DOUG MCERLEAN: Hey, so I'm Doug.
I'm one of the engineers
on the Cloud Bigtable team.
And I'm one of the developers
of the replication feature.
And Carter just painted a
pretty cool picture, right?
You can put your data anywhere.
We'll keep it in sync for you.
You don't have to do
anything except click
a couple of buttons.
I'm sure some of you are
wondering how true that really
is, right?
What are the asterisks
on this announcement?
Do you have to change
your apps that are running
to be safe with replication?
Do you need to stop your traffic
while you're setting it up?
Do you need to lock in your
topology first and then copy
data into it yourself?
And can you really put
data anywhere you want?
Or are there restrictions there?
And it turns out the answer
to all these questions is no.
You don't have any
of these asterisks.
We will take care of all
of these things for you.
And I am going to
hopefully show you
how easy this is live on stage.
This is a terrifying
demo to give.
But so like Carter
mentioned, we've
got 12 Ts sitting
in Oregon right now.
And I am going to
click a couple buttons.
And we're going to copy it--
if we want to go to the next
slide--
to South Carolina,
Finland, and Taiwan.
And with any luck,
it's going to be
done by the time I come
back up in 20 or 30 minutes.
So in order to get this
started, we're just
going to go over to--
can we get the demo up?
We go over to the
Edit Instance page.
And I want to emphasize this
is the Edit Instance page, not
the Create Instance page.
You're able to change
this whenever you want.
And all you have to do is add
clusters to your instance.
Every cluster is a set
of nodes in a zone.
And every cluster in your
instance serves every table.
And if you change your mind
later, deletes are also safe.
We'll hold that data
behind the scenes for you
until it's safely copied out.
So I'm just going to add
a couple clusters here.
All right, first, US East 1.
That's South Carolina.
And then we're going
to add Europe North
1, which is Finland.
And then we're going to add
Asia East 1, which is Taiwan.
And then I'm just
going to hit Save.
And now we're done, right?
I can leave.
So this is going to spin
for a couple seconds.
Then we're going to show you
what's actually going on.
All right, so we're back
on the Instance Overview.
And we see already we've
got four clusters here.
We've got some
spinners over here.
A couple of them are
already finished.
We're provisioning nodes.
And what this means is as
soon as this spinner is done,
you can create a new table
and start using it right away.
These clusters are happy
to do that for you.
Over on the right, we
see some other spinners.
Those are for your
existing tables, which
have started copying over.
And that's what I'm going
to come back up and show,
hopefully, finished
in a little bit.
But we can see some
of the progress
there by going over to
the tables list page.
All right, so this
says we've got the one
table with all this data.
And it's copying.
And you can expand this to
show its state in each cluster.
It's copying in all
of them right now.
These are going to turn
into progress bars.
There's one right now.
It's at 1%.
All of these are eventually
going to start going.
And hopefully they should
all be green later on.
But another thing
that I mentioned
is do you have to stop your
traffic while this is going on?
Is it unsafe to keep writing?
And the answer is no.
And to show that, I've actually
got a loop running already
which is writing victory into
row Athens in this table.
And you can see that here.
All of this is going to
the original cluster.
And even as these new
clusters come online--
if we go back to the slide--
we've got-- and can
we go to the next one?
We've got default routing.
This comes out of the box.
You don't have to do anything.
If you don't tell
us what to do, we
are going to keep
your traffic flowing
as it always has to the original
cluster in your instance.
And this is so that
you don't have to make
any changes to set this up.
All your existing
apps keep working.
And these new copies are
essentially backups until you
tell us otherwise.
So all these writes are going
into the original cluster.
And just to show there's
nothing up my sleeve,
I'm going to show you
the command that I ran.
This is a simple loop
over the CPT command line.
It's doing a set for
demo table, row Athens,
the demo column
family equals victory.
So I'm going to start
running that again.
And that's going to
go the whole time.
And then when I come
back, we're going
to count how many
times this wrote
into the original cluster.
And we're going to count
how many times it wrote
into one of the new copies.
And they should be the
same, because we're
keeping the data in sync.
And so with that, I'm going
to hand things back to Carter.
CARTER PAGE: Hello?
All right, thanks, Doug.
OK, so we got that kicked off.
We'll come back later
and do some fun things
with this new global
instance we have set up.
All right, so I'm going to
talk a little bit about what
is Cloud Bigtable,
and how does it work,
and what do you
actually use it for?
So first let me get into
the replication thing
that we're talking about here.
So a year ago, we announced
a regional replication
which allowed you to
put multiple clusters
into a single region.
So it used to be
a zonal service.
And now you could
have two zones,
two clusters running in separate
zones in a single region.
And this gave you
a few benefits.
It gave you an extra 9 on your
SLA by expanding your failure
domains.
It allowed users to isolate
serve and analytics workloads.
And some presenters
have actually
talked about how they do that.
Spotify does this
a bit where you
can, say, have one cluster
that is serving low latency
traffic to your customers.
And you have another
cluster that you're
pounding with a
MapReduce or Dataflow job
and just beating
it up, essentially.
You can have isolation
so they're not
interfering with each other.
To that point, you can
also independently scale
the clusters.
So you could scale
up your batch cluster
to make that go faster
while that's happening,
and keep your serve cluster
at a different level.
And it also provides, if
you're using the application
profile that supports
this, then you
would get automatic failover.
So if one zone failed,
all of your traffic
would automatically
go to the other zone.
So today what we're announcing
is the GA global replication.
And there's two main
changes with this.
This allows you, one,
you get to replicate
between four zones, not two.
And it completely removes the
restriction on what region
those zones are in.
So, as I mentioned
before, you could put one
on the East Coast,
or the West Coast.
You could put two--
you could have a
Japanese cluster.
You could have one in
Osaka, one in Tokyo.
And then you can also fan
these out around the globe.
And I'll talk a little bit
about why you might use
some of these different things.
So Bigtable itself--
the main reasons
to use Bigtable is
speed and low latency.
So it's a very high
throughput system.
And this throughput is
nice and linearly scalable.
We did a presentation
a couple of years
ago, in fact, where
we demonstrated
that Bigtable could handle--
we threw 3,000 nodes up.
And we were able to get 30
million QPS durable writes
and 30 gigabytes per second.
And that was far from the
peak of what we could actually
pull off on the system.
The other thing
that you get while--
this is kind of the
remarkable thing
is there's other ways you can
do very high speed ingestion.
But the trick about
Bigtable is while you're
blasting this data in, the split
second, or split nanosecond,
after we acknowledge your write,
it is immediately accessible
for reads.
And the read
latency is very low,
so single digit
millisecond latency.
So if you're using flash, maybe
three to four milliseconds,
HDD maybe a couple
of milliseconds more.
But generally, the
long tail itself
stays within about
10 milliseconds.
And that's a nice set
of characteristics.
And then with this you get
a very linear scalability.
So the knob use on Bigtable--
the only knob we give you
for configuration is nodes.
So you start with three as
your basic production cluster.
And then you can scale it up
from three, to 10, to 300.
And as mentioned, we've gone
as high as 3,000 before.
And the thing that's kind
of nifty about Bigtable
is the scalability curve is
actually linear well beyond--
from 30 at least to
the 30 million point.
And that's pretty nifty,
because usually these curves
start to flatten out a
little bit over time.
Internally, we've optimized
the bottlenecks enough
where it goes linear way beyond
these bounds, essentially.
And this is valuable
for planning,
in terms of thinking about
how many nodes you're going
to need for a different load.
You don't have to test it out.
Once you get certain sample
loads that are representative,
you know, get a
good sense of what
size cluster you
would need to handle,
say 10x that, 100x that.
It's also good for
business purposes,
because if your
business is attached
to the amount of
operations that you're
having on your
Bigtable, then you
could predict cost of revenue.
And that's useful.
So part of the way
that Bigtable does this
is that abstracts
out the storage
from the actual
processing layer.
So your Bigtable nodes
are essentially--
they're kind of quasi
stateless things
that sit on top of the actual
storage system, which is a file
system called Colossus, which is
a newer generation system that
replaced our earlier
Google File System.
And the nodes are
responsible for making sure
that the data is there
to be read quickly.
So it's holding onto
the indexes in memory.
And it's also channeling
your data through
to make sure you're getting that
really nice write throughput.
But by keeping them separate,
you can do some cool things.
Like we can do really aggressive
re-balancing, which we do.
So imagine the A
over there represents
a single chunk of data.
And this chunk of data is
getting a lot of activity.
Maybe it's a pattern that
crops up every day at 2:30
in the afternoon.
And what Bigtable
will do is we'll
say, OK, so A is getting hot.
So I'm going to start moving
things off of this node
so this node can serve more
of the A traffic, essentially.
And Bigtable does
this fairly quickly.
It checks these patterns
every couple of minutes
or so and just
keeps re-balancing.
It does this all day, every day.
So even as patterns
change throughout the day,
Bigtable will come back and keep
readjusting the same patterns
as it sees them day in, day out.
Another advantage is
you get very, very easy
resizing, very fast resizing.
So if you're familiar with
other systems like Cassandra
and things like that where you
have to deal with re-indexing,
resizing is kind of a pain
in a lot of those systems.
Here, you can just
throw nodes at it.
The nodes will be
available in seconds.
It'll take several
minutes for us
to re-balance to get the
maximum bin packing of your load
onto these nodes.
And then you can do some
cool things with this.
So one is it's good for
operational issues--
surprise traffic, just
throw some nodes at it.
Another could be at the
end of the week maybe
you have a large batch
process which takes 10 hours.
And you wish it
would take one hour.
So you just up your cluster
by 10x, run your batch load,
and then spin it
back down again.
OK, so here's a few
different use cases.
So one is Ad tech.
So Google has a little bit of
Ad tech inside our company.
And we do a lot of this
stuff on top of Bigtable.
It's a low latency
system, which is nice.
And what you can do is you can
use Google Replication to put
your data where your users are.
So Bigtable's already low
latency, as I mentioned.
But then if you can
actually put your data
even closer to your
customers, then that
can shave off milliseconds
of network traffic.
So in this example,
we have a zone
set up on the east coast, the
west coast, and central US.
Another example is
financial services.
And this gets to the
disaster recovery
situation I was talking about.
You could set up
a couple of zones
to be your primary high
availability service--
pretty close to Wall Street.
You're not going to do high
frequency trading on this,
but it's good enough for back
office operations and things
like that.
It's still going to be very
fast and very high throughput.
And then we've got a
South Carolina zone that's
about 400 miles to the south.
And so you could set that up.
And we will just be
replicating your data there.
If you have a problem--
you know, if Norfolk,
Virginia goes down,
if there's a
hurricane or whatever,
then we will automatically
failover to South Carolina.
Or if you prefer, we could
have a manual failover
to South Carolina.
And your recovery
point objective
is going to be measured
in minutes, again,
in the worst case--
that would be the long tail
of the replication latency.
Most of your data will
be there in just seconds.
And your replication
time objective,
if you're doing
automatic failover,
can be measured in seconds.
The third case I'll mention
and the third case guess
I'll go into detail on is IoT.
So we have a lot
of customers who
use us for telemetry storage.
There's actually a lot
of industrial IoT cases.
There's a cool company
called [INAUDIBLE],,
which uses us for oil
platforms and shipping.
Go check them out
on the expo floor.
It's pretty neat.
In this case, I'm giving an
example of commercial IoT,
where imagine you have a
mobile phone app, maybe,
that collects data
on exercise habits.
And you want to have a
conversation, essentially,
with your customer.
You're getting telemetry
data from the customer.
You want to process that
data, give them advice back.
If you just have
your data in the US,
then you're going to have a poor
experience for everybody else.
In this case, you could
throw one cluster in each
of your four different--
in four different continents,
and be close to customers
all around the world,
essentially-- low
latency everywhere.
And then you could
have your data--
you could do your analytics
in a single place.
So imagine you make your Iowa
cluster a little bit bigger.
And that's getting all the
data from all of the other four
continents.
And then you're running maybe
longer daily batch processing
on that data, as well.
So other use cases for
Cloud Bigtable-- we
have gaming customers.
Again, the low
latency there is nice,
being able to get a lot of
data from a lot of users
that high write
throughput is useful.
It's a big data system.
So genome sequencing is
another use case for Bigtable.
And then energy,
utilities, and telecom all
have variations of
things that work well
for Bigtable--
geospatial data, again,
things that often look
like the IoT use cases
I was talking about
before, as well.
But to make all this work,
you have the software
that has Cloud Bigtable.
But we're kind of
glossing over the fact
that the data has
to actually move
between these different places.
And that's actually
really the hard part.
And you need to make
this network work.
It has to scale.
It has to handle an
immense amount of traffic.
We're moving 10 terabytes here.
We can move a lot more
than that, actually.
And it needs to
be cost efficient.
Your business needs to
be able to afford it.
And it needs to be
available all the time.
So to make this work, we
have a special network.
And Subhasree is going
to talk about the network
and the software that
makes this possible.
Subhasree--
SUBHASREE MANDAL:
Thank you, Carter.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Subhasree.
And I'm going to talk about
the network that supports
these kind of applications.
So at Google, we believe network
is a key differentiator when
it comes to building
an application that's
scalable and available.
So Google has been investing
quite a bit in this technology
for over a decade.
The network infrastructure
team in Google
have been building
a unique network
infrastructure especially
driven by Google's needs.
Google's compute and
storage infrastructure
needed something that didn't
exist in the industry.
So we built unique and
innovative products.
And many of them have been
published as research papers.
And they have influenced
the industry, the academia.
But most importantly, they have
served Google's applications--
the essential applications
that have over a billion users,
like Search, Gmail, YouTube.
And going forward, the
same infrastructure
is going to be available
for our Google--
our cloud customers who can
build their products on that.
So this is a snapshot
of Google Cloud network.
The locations here
are cloud regions,
current and future ones.
And not all of them are
Cloud Bigtable regions yet.
The footprints keep growing.
And I would like us to focus
on the dense graph that
connects these locations.
There are plenty of
terrestrial links,
as well a lot of
trans-oceanic links.
And these trans-oceanic
links are quite interesting.
We will talk about those
a little more in details.
Some of these
trans-oceanic links Google
actually have invested in.
For example, you can see there
is one from Florida to Brazil.
It's called Monet
cable system that's
operated by Google along with
a few other telecom companies.
We'll talk more about those.
So talking about the
density of the graph,
that reflects the scale and
availability of the network.
So the application, like the
one we are going to demonstrate,
is not running on
public internet.
It's trending on a
private global backbone
that's run by Google.
So every packet
traverses a router
that's controlled by Google.
And one of the
catastrophic failures
in a normal network is fiber
that causes partition and that
causes system
inconsistencies, et cetera--
are quite rare in
this kind of scenario.
So many of these
regions are actually
hosted in our
massive data centers.
And each data center by rule has
at least three different fibers
that connect it to the
global network, which
means fiber cut,
which is often treated
as a catastrophic
failure, is not
a catastrophic
failure in this case.
And yet another example is the
trans-Atlantic connectivity.
As you can see, there are
six different fiber routes
that connect our
North American regions
to our European regions.
What does that mean?
That definitely
talks about scale.
Each of these fibers can
carry several terabits
per second of traffic.
And there are six of them.
And we expect them to
fail independently,
which means we can
provide stricter bandwidth
guarantee over these
links across the ocean.
And next, I'm going to show
you a little bit of the
behind the scenes story
how this is built.
So this is a cartoon
view of one of those six
trans-Atlantic cables that
connects Virginia to London.
And this is, of course,
not drawn to scale.
I have a sample
cable for you to see.
You can come and take a
look after the presentation.
So it's probably not as
thick as you would imagine.
I can wrap my fingers
easily around it.
And at the center
of this cable, there
is the optical fiber
that carries the signal
as pulses of light.
I also have a spool of
25 kilometers of fiber.
Take a look at it,
if you want, later.
So each of these
fibers, it's made
of glass-- very
high quality glass
with no impurities whatsoever.
And each of these
fiber strand, it's
approximately as thick
as a strand of hair.
But it can carry 100
terabits per second of data.
What does that mean?
100 terabits per
second would translate
to something like 10 million
streaming YouTube videos.
And as you can see, the
thickness of the cable
gets thicker, gets
wider near the shore,
because it's high
risk for damage.
And these are laid
out using ships.
You can see a cartoon
version of that.
Sometimes there are two
ships coming from two ends.
And in the middle of
the ocean, the cable
is lifted off the ocean floor,
and spliced, and buried back
into the ocean bed.
We'll see a video soon.
And we lay out these paths.
We survey the path
earlier so that we
avoid rough terrains, and
coral reefs, hungry sharks--
so we'll see them in a bit.
So water is not the
first thing that
will come to mind when
you talk about networking.
However, this is where a large
chunk of our network lives--
not in the data centers.
Data centers do have
a piece, though.
And even though we
don't think about water,
but 2/3 of the Earth's
surface is covered with water,
which means we cannot build
a network around the globe
without laying cables
under these water bodies.
The network is slow.
But people have been laying out
these cables for a long time,
for over 150 years.
And these were not for
this kind of data network.
It was for telegraphy.
What has changed
more recently is
what goes inside these cables.
So we'll see in a bit how
these cables are constructed
and how they are
laid out spatially
with the example of
Monet Cable System.
In the center of the cable,
we have the glass fiber.
These are typically color coded.
Why?
If we want to repair, we want
to splice blue with blue and red
with red.
These are used for
identification.
And these are
typically allocated
pairwise, one in
each direction--
transmit and receive.
And of course, there are a
lot of protective layers.
There is one layer
that is very special.
That's the copper layer.
Because it's not
just for protection.
It's used for carrying
power to the repeaters that
sit along the path.
And after, with
all these layers,
it's now ready to be
buried under the sea floor.
And if any of you happen to
visit the Sunnyvale office,
we have a model of
one of these boats.
Feel free to check it out.
What about them?
Maybe we trained them.
Actually, to speak
the truth, the sharks
do bite these cables
once in a while.
But with all the
protective layers,
they do not really damage the
cables or cause an outage.
So we cannot really blame them.
Now, back to how
this network is used.
So one key observation
is that there
is a lot more traffic
between servers
than a server and an user.
And the inter-server traffic
is not only high in volume,
it also has very
different characteristics.
It's more bursty, there's
no smooth diurnal pattern,
and more amenable
to classification.
There's so much of this
traffic that we built
a whole separate backbone.
We call it B4.
That's our backend backbone
that connects our data centers.
And people say
developers at Google
get to use wide area
network just like people
get to use local area network
in other places thanks to B4.
But this privilege should
not be limited just
to Google Developers.
With Cloud offerings
like Cloud Bigtable,
this network would be available
to our cloud users, as well.
So what does it take to
build a network like this?
Scale is, of course, a
very challenging goal.
And everything at Google
has to be built at scale.
And in presence of scale, other
goals also become challenging.
One thing to note here is
that as our compute scales,
network scales quadratically
because of its source dist
pairwise nature, which means
unit cost does not necessarily
go down, unlike
computer storage.
And availability, of
course, is our final goal.
Without availability,
bandwidth makes no sense.
So I'll talk about
two approaches
that we take to build
a network like this.
One is a hardware approach.
And one is a software approach.
So in terms of
hardware, we do not
use lot of expensive
feature rich routers.
We use cheap commodity hardware.
We mesh them and
build big switches.
So Supergate is our
regional network
that we use in most
of our data centers
to connect zones
within the region
and pair with other regions.
And it delivers 1.6
petabits per second
of non-blocking capacity.
And 1.6 petabits
per second would
translate to a few hundred
million streaming videos.
And that's all within a region.
And this picture shows
one of the eight building
blocks of Supergate.
It's built with a few
hundred cheap commodity
switches meshed to provide
2,000 ports, each with 100 gig
capacity.
So this is the hardware
piece of the solution.
And on the software
side, we follow
a philosophy called
software-defined networking
technology.
The main idea is to take the
smarts out of the network
and run them in servers
that are available.
In traditional network
routing and control software
typically runs on the CPU
that lives inside the routers,
which is limited.
So for us, these get to run
on powerful Google servers.
And we get to leverage all of
Google's distributed computing
infrastructure.
As a result, we can run
advanced optimization algorithms
pretty fast and utilize
all the links that
have been deployed optimally.
That means our network
is more efficient.
And also, because of the
good compute infrastructure,
the algorithms
converge faster, which
means if there is a fiber cut,
the network converges fast.
So that produces
high availability.
It's much faster compared to
traditional MPLS/RSVP style
networks.
So with all these,
what have we achieved?
So the graph on the left shows
how the scale of our network
has grown in recent
five year period.
The traffic has grown by
two orders of magnitude.
And at the same time, actually
the last year of that period,
we have measured availability.
And it has gone up
by at least one nine.
One nine actually translates
to 10x improvement
in availability.
And hierarchical
control system based
on software-defined networking
allowed us to do this.
With that, I am
going to wrap up.
We are not done yet.
The network continues to evolve,
because Google believes network
is a key differentiator.
And we have to continue to
evolve and invest in it.
We are not only delivering
new features, as needed
by our customers, which is
Google applications and cloud
applications, we are
growing in scale.
We continue to innovate,
upgrade in place.
And we continue to improve scale
availability and decrease cost.
With that, I'm going to
hand it over to Carter.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CARTER PAGE: Thanks,
thanks Subhasree.
1.6 petabits per second is
pretty bonkers, isn't it?
All right, so we
learned about how
the software defined
network and all this fiber
that we own or share--
some of it we own,
some of it we share--
allows us to have the scale,
the cost effectiveness,
and the availability
to provide the data
locality around the world
for a solution like Bigtable.
So what we're going to do now is
we're going to go back to Doug.
All right, we're going
to pray to the demo gods.
And let's see how we're doing.
DOUG MCERLEAN: So I'm smiling.
The last one finished
10 seconds ago.
The other two have
been done for a bit.
So just to remind what we were
doing, we are running writes--
yeah, there we go.
We're running writes
through default routing.
We're writing
victory into Athens.
And that's going to the
original cluster in Oregon.
And we have
replication set up now
between these four
regions around the world.
So if we cut back to the--
there-- so you can see
these are all done.
We're waiting on a local pass to
collect disk usage on this one,
because it just finished.
But everything is all set up.
Replication is running.
So the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to throw
over to the monitoring page
to show that we've been
writing the whole time.
And then we're going
to kill these writes.
They've served their purpose.
And we're going to see how
many times this write happened
in the original cluster
so we can sort of check
for consistency here.
So I'm going to run
this command here.
This is, again, the
CBT command line tool.
It's pointed at this table.
It's doing a lookup now into
demo table for row Athens.
I'm going to grep for victory.
And I'm going to count
the lines that come back.
And we've got 3,115.
So now what we want
to do is see if that's
the number somewhere else.
But like I said,
this default routing,
if we don't tell where
to send the request,
it's going to go to
this original cluster.
So we need to set
some routing rules up.
To do that, I'm going to go
over here into the application
profiles page.
This is a cool feature I'm
going to talk a little bit more
in a second.
But just to keep
things going, we're
going to create one of these.
These let you
control your routing
at a fine grained level.
And so I'm going to create
one called check copy,
give a little description.
And I'll point this at,
say, the Asia cluster.
So this is C4.
And I'll create it.
And all this is is an ID that
you've set up with the server.
And then when you send
this ID with a request,
we will route things as
you set up for that ID.
So we've created
the new profile.
Here, you can see the
old one, the default.
And that's routing at C1,
which is the original thing.
And now we just run
this command again.
All we have to do is add app
profile equals check copy.
Run it again, and we
should get 3,115 again.
And there it is.
So even though we
were writing before,
during, and after these
copies, replication
has kept this data in sync.
It took probably only about
two seconds for this to come
across, which is sort of the
typical 99th percentile number
that we generally see for
these sorts of setups,
especially since there's
not a lot of traffic
here to begin with.
So replication did
the heavy lifting.
I just want to talk about app
profiles for a little bit.
And then I'll show
a monitoring graph--
it just takes a
little while to load--
that shows that this actually
routed where we said it did.
So app profiles, like
I said, are an ID
that you set up in advance.
And I want to plug
these to people who
are looking into replication.
I also want to plug
these for people
who are just using Bigtable and
not ready for replication yet.
All an app profile is is a
way to slice your traffic.
We provide some config
on the server side
to let you control routing.
But even if you don't
need that, it still
gives you per
application monitoring.
So you can see, for
example, how much
traffic is coming from your
batch job versus your streaming
ingestion versus your live
traffic serving reads.
And that's a useful
feature on its own.
In addition, if you setup
one of these per app,
if you do want to
adopt replication,
it gives you a fine grained
way to just move over
one app at a time when
it's ready for replication.
And everything else will just
do what it was doing before.
And the best part
about that is you
can just reroute it from here.
You don't have to down your
app or change any code.
You just change the
server side config.
And we'll re-route
everything for you.
So hopefully I
have convinced you.
And hopefully I've also
talked long enough for this
to finish loading.
So if we just go over
to monitoring again--
so we see one read here.
Looks like we did not
quite have enough time
to see the other read come in.
So I'll return to this later.
I want to jump over
to another instance
now and show you some
disaster recovery.
This is something that
Carter alluded to before.
And this is something that
replication makes very easy.
So if you can go
over to the slides,
just show a nice diagram
of what we're going to do--
go a couple forward.
So the new setup that
we have in this instance
is we've got a primary serving
cluster in Iowa, US central.
And we've got a backup
cluster in Oregon.
And we've also got a load
generator running in Iowa.
And it's using failover,
or any cluster routing.
This goes nearest first.
So whichever cluster is close,
that's what we're going to use.
And we will only
try the other one
if the first request is slow
or errors out for some reason.
And so you can see here
the traffic by default
is all going to go right back
into Iowa where it started.
So if we cut back
to the demo, you
can see that that's
exactly what's happening.
We've got these two clusters.
And right there you see that all
that 20,000 writes per second,
they're all going to
the serve cluster.
And none of them are going
to the backup right now.
Another thing that
I want to point out
is that the backup is smaller.
The backup's not taking
any live traffic.
And the replication load
that we're sending to it
is a little bit more
efficient, because we
can kind of batch and window
things behind the scenes.
So even though it has one
third the compute power
of the serve cluster, it's
still able to keep up,
which is all it has to do.
It's just trying to keep this
hot swappable copy of the data
alive.
So from there, we're going to go
back to the edit instance page.
And we're going to simulate
what happens if that
serve cluster goes down.
Imagine there's a lot of fiber
cuts, or there's a tornado--
a big outage in the zone
that makes most or all
of your requests start failing.
I'm going to
simulate this by just
deleting the serve cluster.
And this is something
that I encourage
people to try themselves if
they're using replication
for this purpose,
because it lets
you get a feel for
what you need to do
in the event of a
failover situation.
So you can see already--
I don't know if anybody was
looking at the CPU before.
The CPU is already going
up in the backup cluster.
This is going to
update in a little bit
the writes per second.
But behind the scenes, what's
happening is everything
is rerouting.
It only takes a few
seconds for this to happen.
It takes longer, unfortunately,
for the metrics to actually
show up on the screen.
So imagine this did happen.
Let's actually just go
back to the slides so we
can get a nice picture of this.
And go to the next one.
This is going to route
everything to Oregon now.
If this actually happens, there
are a few things going on.
In this case, the
cluster is gone.
But if the cluster were still
there and throwing errors,
every request is going to
take a little bit of time
to realize something's
up and failover.
So that's going to add
a little bit of latency.
And the fact that
it has to go further
is also going to add a
little bit of latency.
But the requests are still
going to get served eventually.
So this is a graceful
degradation situation.
A couple of things that you
want to deal with here--
number one, you might
want to sort of cut out
that failover latency.
So in the real world, the
other cluster's still there.
It's throwing errors.
You'd want to try to delete it.
If the zone is really
completely inaccessible,
you might not be able to.
But it's a good practice
to try that out first.
And then the next thing that
you're going to want to do
is size up the backup cluster.
Carter mentioned this
is very easy to do.
All you have to do, again,
is click a couple buttons.
And this is because we
provisioned it lower
for cost saving purposes.
But now it's actually
taking the full traffic.
And so we're going to
want to make it bigger
so that it can handle the
throughput without falling
behind.
Requests will be
served a little slower,
but they won't knock
the cluster over.
And that's already done.
In the next few
minutes, we're going
to start re-balancing the load.
And you're going to see the
CPU utilization go down.
Now hopefully--
again, those graphs
take a little while to load.
But hopefully we can see
already the initial failover
from this going on.
Yeah, so right here, you can
see traffic falling off a cliff
to the serve cluster
and traffic coming up
to the backup cluster.
It's not quite all the
way to where it was.
And that's a consequence
of that extra latency.
But the failover is working.
And so once you've
sort of handled
the immediate emergency,
things are still
in the degraded state.
We're going to do what
we did in the other demo.
And we're just going
to add another cluster
to set up replication
someplace else that's working.
So we can add a cluster.
Say, if it's just
a zonal outage,
the original one was
in US central 1B.
We can add a cluster
in US central 1C.
And it will be
copied in the time
that it takes to come up
and talk about networking.
And that'll spin for a bit.
And then it will be done.
So that's failover.
I just want to check back
over here and see if I-- yup,
so this is the original
demo, just showing
that that second read request
went to the other cluster.
And that's it.
I'm going to hand
things back to Carter.
CARTER PAGE: All
right, thanks Doug.
So back to the slides here--
so just to wrap up, you get--
with the failover
solution, we saw
that we were able to get fast
global access to a single data
set.
We copied terabytes of
data in just minutes.
We do basically heavily
parallelized writes
over this massive fiber network.
So we're actually able
to copy a lot of data
in a short amount of time.
And it's so fast,
as you noticed,
one of the things we were
talking about is, hey,
we need an extra cluster
in our instance--
let's just spin up another
one on the other side
of the continent and
just copy the data there.
And that's actually something
that works pretty well.
You get disaster
recovery out of the box.
Scaling up, scaling
down takes seconds.
And you can re-route
individual applications.
You can use
application profiles,
configure each different
application using
a different profile,
even if they're all
using the same routing rules.
That gives you a lot of
flexibility operationally
until you decide what you
want to do with that traffic.
So in summary, with
global data replication
you get a global presence.
So you're basically a global
local presence, essentially.
You get the low
latency of being local.
But that data is kept in
sync around the entire world
in seconds, typically, and
in minutes on the long tail.
You have single digit
milliseconds latency,
as I mentioned.
It's a very high scale system.
We haven't found anyone who can
push it beyond its limits yet.
If you think you can,
we want to talk to you.
And we have an out
of the box disaster
recovery solution
with this, as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]